George Clooney had a warning for Ben  Affleck about Batman I actually did I  did talk to about yeah I said don't do  it George explained why during The  Hollywood Reporter's Awards chatter  podcast he worked his way back from  actor jail you know which happens when  you do when I do Batman and Robin and  when he does  yeah GE yeah sure so it's that right he  gets to that moment and I thought don't  don't give him something to fire off at  you did great though Ben didn't take the  advice and may have regretted it oh my  god such a pain in the ass it's like  every time I mentioned Batman it gets  this huge you know clickbait george try  to tell you he tried to tell you George  may through this I am Hutton when George  speaks listen by the way  Ben has since that he is done playing  the Caped Crusader but let's go back to  Clooney for a sec yeah hey because  George has something in common with the  newest royal Archie they had the same  birthday  you